Christian Elder, Screenwriter: Being
a writer of putting in those hours of
spending that time of building your voice as
a writer and to have conviction as a writer.
Film Courage: I believe you've referenced
Dorothy Parker many times where you say
the famous remark of her’s “I hate
to write, I love having written.” We
were talking a little bit about her off
screen how do you relate to that quote.
Christian: Absolutely I relate
to that quote. Writing is hard.
It's tough for a couple of reasons. There's two
sides of that coin that the actual activity itself
is is taxing and it requires a lot of
patience and also it is one of those
chosen vocations where one is likely to suffer
a great deal of critique, scrutiny and attack.
All of that together makes it makes it tough
so you have to sort of build a sort of thick
skin. Now with that comes the great myths
of the writers and and all the writers that
I can think of and this is across all genres of
writing most of them have this aura of strength
and promotion of that strength as a writer
and in their writing and those and the finest
examples of it is Dorothy Parker is a probably
one of the pinnacles of that idea of strength
as well as someone of course like Ernest
Hemingway, Hunter S. Thompson, James Baldwin
all of these characters convey strength and that
is a quality that comes from having to deal with
the rigors of being a writer of putting in those
hours of spending that time of building your voice
as a writer and to have conviction as a writer and
and it also speaks to something a little bit that
we talked about just a few minutes ago which was
that the character that you were referring to in
Michael Clayton and that is they don't really
fit in this box they don't fit in that box
there's not really a place for them but they can't
just fade away this is true, this is absolutely
true I think that's an interesting analogy and
an interesting point that you're bringing up
I think that once you go down the road as is it
I always get I'm Thoreau and Emerson I'm confused
but I believe it was Thoreau The Road Not Taken
so to speak once you go down the road not taken
a friend of mine used to say it's it gets a little
sketchy down there because the road not taken is
often patrolled by the cops so once you go down
that road don't expect to not face adversity
and don't expect it to not change you don't
expect to not to not make you something that
you don't expect that you're going to be you
will you will more than likely become smarter
wiser you will you will have survival skills that
you probably didn't expect that you would gain
but it will turn you into something else that's
really interesting for better or worse yes you're
right I like what you said how going down this
road that there's not it's kind of a dark murky
road where you're not really sure what's in the
shadows but it also is maybe sort of a metaphor
for what a lot of writers have been maybe more
alone or I know outcast is is not the right word
but they're used to having to be their own
strength well I mean to a degree I mean like
I know a lot of writers and I've spent a lot
of time around writers this is a whole other
subject matter we can get into this in a bit
but but being alone as a writer is not so bad
because writers aren't really alone it's
a kind of illusion because writers are
besieged with the often with especially if they're
writing stories they're besieged with characters
that live with them so and it's this misnomer to
say a writer is alone in fact it's like writers
writers in a sense if you want to if you want
to call them anti-social they aren't anti-social
by I think by nature they're anti-social by choice
because they just want to get back
to the people they know [Laughter]
they're you're currently entertained
with and I think that's really what it is
I think also conversely many writers
are extraordinarily gregarious
my personal M.O. [modus operandi]
I think is that I have two sides
and those two sides are I can be
incredibly quiet totally bashful really shy
a real introvert and then I swing way to
the other side and I can be incredibly
gregarious and extrovert and and highly
social and and loud and boisterous and all
those things I don't know what that means
and but I do know that that it that is not
that is not something that is unusual that
that many, many writers are fill that mold.